both probably you and I
would have certain interests with the
base model with open Echo as the base
model which is before the the alignment
of the
reinforcement learning with human
feedback and and before the
AI safety-based kind of censorship of
the model
it would be fascinating to explore to
investigate the ways that the model can
generate hate speech
the kind of hate that humans are capable
of it would be fascinating or the kind
of of course like uh sexual language or
the kind of romantic language or the all
kinds of ideologies can I get it to be a
communist can I get it to be a fascist
can I get it to be a capitalist can I
get it to be all these kinds of things
and see which parts get activated and
not because it would be fascinating to
sort of explore at the individual mind
level and at a societal level where do
these ideas
take hold what is the fundamental core
of those ideas maybe the communism
fascism capitalism democracy are all
actually connected by the fact that the
human heart the human mind is drawn to
ideology
to a centralizing idea and maybe we need
a neural network to remind us of that I
like the concept that the human mind is
somehow tied to ideology and I think
that goes back to the the promptability
of jgbt the fact that you can kind of
say well think in this particular way
now and the fact that humans have
infected words for encapsulating these
types of behaviors and it's hard to know
how much of that is innate and how much
of that was like passed on from language
to language
but basically if you look at the
evolution of language you can kind of
see how young are these words in the
history of language Evolution that
describe these types of behaviors like
you know kindness and anger and jealousy
Etc
if these words are very similar from
language to language it might suggest
that they're very ancient if they're
very different it might suggest that
this concept may have emerged
independently in each different language
and so and so forth so
looking at the phylogeny the history The
evolutionary traces of language at the
same time as people moving around that
we can now Trace thanks to genetics
is a fascinating way of understanding
the human psyche and also understanding
sort of how these types of behaviors
emerge and to go back to your idea about
sort of exploring the system unfiltered
I mean in a way this is a psychiatric
hospitals are full of those people of
those people so basically people whose
mind is uncontrollable yes who have kind
of gone adrift in specific locations of
their psyche and I I do find this
fascinating basically
you know watching movies that are trying
to capture the essence of troubled minds
I think is teaching us so much about our
everyday selves because many of us are
able to sort of control our minds and
are able to have somehow somehow hide
these emotions and
but every time I see somebody who's
troubled I I see versions of myself
maybe not as extreme but I can sort of
empathize with these behaviors and
you know I see bipolar I see
schizophrenia I see depression I see
autism I see so many different aspects
that we kind of have names for and
crystallize in specific individuals
and I think all of us have that all of
us have sort of just these
multi-dimensional brain and genetic
variations that push us in these
directions environmental exposures and
traumas that push us in these directions
environmental behaviors that are
reinforced by the kind of friends that
we chose or friends that we were stuck
with because of the environments that we
grew up in so in a way a lot of these
types of
behaviors
are within the Vector span of every
human it's just that the magnitude of
those vectors is generally smaller for
most people
because they haven't inherited that
particular set of genetic variants or
because they haven't been exposed to
those environments basically or
something about the mechanism of
reinforcement learning with human
feedback didn't quite work for them so
it's fascinating to think about that's
what we do we have this capacity to have
all these
psychiatric or behaviors associated with
psychiatric disorders but we through the
alignment process as we go through their
parents we kind of we know to suppress
them yeah we know the how to control
every human that grows up in this in
this world spends several decades being
shaped into place yeah and without that
you know maybe we would have the
unfiltered lgbt4